cette émission consacrée aux pays-bas
l'eau il doit permettre à prof de la
culture et des traditions galère mais
qu'est ce que le pays gagnent et mal
connue parce que mal défini et peut être
difficile à définir
il apparaît comme un pays quand pompe la
basse bretagne le pays
retenant et le reste de l'hexagone il a
donc suivi leur influence que ce soit
pour la langue la musique ou la danse
cette bretagne orientale pendant
longtemps s'est tu à présent elle veut
elle aussi retrouver ses racines et les
faire connaître
c'est pourquoi on assiste actuellement
avait très nombreuses initiatives dans
ce sens que ce soit de la part
individuelle de groupe d'associations
chacun entreprend une remise en valeur
du patrimoine culturel du pays gallo le
cercle doute privé de saint grégoire que
vous voyez aujourd'hui se consacrent
quant à lui essentiellement à latence ya
la musique située aux portes de rennes
il s'est spécialisé dans l'étude du
bassin rennais et contribue à la
revalorisation et une plus large
diffusion de cette culture calais grâce
à ces sondes foner danseurs et chanteurs
e
hop
tintin couturiau deux bandeaux
romillonne cette attaque hauturière
déborda rome biya qui à le voir des
filles
le soir après soupe au bout creux à la
la la la la la la la la la et n'a trouvé
la veille dans le coin du fouilleurs et
un trou avec la veille dans le point du
fouilleurs ma fille n'est pas fait pour
un gars couturiau au bout dreux
ah lalala lalala lalala au diable soit
la bei et m'ont foutu monsieur au diable
soit la veille et mon petit monsieur
sans elle et mon oeil je serions marie
aux poudres rah la la la la la la la la
la
avec la plus belle fille du bourg 2 the
avec la plus belle fille du jour 2 ce
qui allait sourcil jaune et le pay to
draw au bout breux lalalalala qui a le
pire en beauce et le jabot de coton qui
a le pire en beauce et le jabot de coton
qui à la goulette heurtaux et le front
charbonneau au bourg à la la la la la la
la la la
à
bagneux la voix mais son comportement
qui n'a fait que j'aime pas mieux abreu
méchant que portait des bottines tout le
temps que porter indafrique qu'accordent
les batignolles tant que porteur matenda
7,4 porter une telle page
et
je ne peux
le rac l'état est avec la roseraie et la
couper la queue à nos pôles le
sacristain l'état vivre grella groupé
larguera nos poules tombé bas c'est
autant de la bombarde un tour n'est pas
et offrant du viendrait à tomber dans
ton style attraper la clé on notera que
raconter
l'attrapé à la travail a tonné longtemps
cantareil hondelatte a un peu ras et à
tournay honda comme ça et on l'attrapé
un attrapé à thomer d'un constat les on
l'atteint pas